liban frais violents affrontements à des
hausses entre milices conservatrice
soldats cible la bio moins cher
l'association internationale a décidé de
libérer les prix du transport aérien
une exclusivité dans le journal
l'interview du chancelier allemand
helmut schmidt quelques jours avant le
conseil européen de braine le tiercé 6 8
2 ils rapportent plus de 6500 francs
dans l'ordre madame mademoiselle
monsieur bonsoir de la pluie encore de
la pluie est toujours de la pluie hélas
la météo qui hier soir nous annonçait un
temps médiocre sur l'ouest le nord et le
bassin parisien ne s'est pas trompé les
averses ont été très fréquente
aujourd'hui sur ces régions mais chose
plus inquiétant encore ce temps humide
couvert et pluvieux devrait paraît-il le
gagner tout le pays demain seuls les
côtes bordant la méditerranée et les
pyrénées seront épargnés certes on ne
s'attend pas à des cataractes mais à une
pluie fine et persistante
un temps qui pour les vacanciers est une
catastrophe finie la baignade il doit
falloir se mettre à la lecture aux
activités manuelles
je vous en reparlerai d'ailleurs à la
fin de cette édition une seule bonne
nouvelle aujourd'hui pour les aspirants
aux vacances mais ce sera probablement
pour celle de l'an prochain les tarifs
aériens vont sérieusement baissé
l'association internationale du
transport aérien l'iata a décidé de
libérer les prix jusqu'à présent les
grandes compagnies ne pouvait lutter
contre les charters désormais ce sera
possible possible et surtout nécessaire
une vaste enquête réalisée il ya
quelques mois aux etats unis démontre
que la notion de confort et de moins en
moins importante alors que l'abaissement
des tarifs est réclamée par tous
d'ailleurs les chiffres par le domaine à
peine 300 mille passagers charter sur
l'atlantique en 64 presque 5 millions en
en fait cette décision de l'association
internationale du transport aérien de
libérer les prix vient consacrer une
réalité économique qu'illustre
parfaitement l'entreprise crédit les
choeurs du nom d'un homme de 55 ans qui
lie à 8 mois casser les prix sur la
traversée de l'atlantique nord avec son
train du ciel pour 500 francs par
personne soit trois fois moins cher que
les compagnies classiques
ils vous emmènent de londres à new york
iata a donc été obligé de céder de peur
de disparaître du temps les petites
compagnies qui craignent d'être menacée
par une telle liberté les prix ont bien
sûr critiqué cette initiative pourtant
inévitable à plus ou moins long terme
nous sommes loin des années 50 où il n'y
avait qu'un tarif unique au dessus de
l'atlantique et où les dîners servis
dans dix-sept cabinet particulier qui se
transforme et la nuit en dix sept
cabinets à deux places aujourd'hui les
prix officiels d'un paris new york et
retour varie de 1750 à 4450 francs mais
en concorde c'est environ nuit quoi
qu'il en soit et en attendant
l'aéroplane pour tous
sachez qu'il ya moins de 10% des pensées
qui utilisent l'avion après une nuit de
calme précaire les affrontements ont
repris ce matin à l'aube à beyrouth tirs
d'armes automatiques tout d'abord et
puis dans l'après midi c'est
l'artillerie qui a donné de la voix
aujourd'hui encore ces combats opposent
la force arabe de dissuasion aux milices
phalangistes et hier plus de 20
personnes ont été tuées a lié jusqu'à
l'année dernière pour s'opposer aux
palestiniens et ennemis aujourd'hui les
forces syriennes patrouillant dans
beyrouth et les milices chrétiennes les
conservateurs depuis hier après midi et
jusqu'à la tombée de la nuit ce sont des
soldats syriens qui depuis les toits des
immeubles avoisinants ont bombardé le
quartier général des phalangistes en
plein centre de beyrouth et cet après
midi les combats se sont étendus à tout
le secteur est de la capitale
l'image presque habituelle d'une guerre
civile qui semble ne jamais vouloir se
terminer sans que l'on sache très bien
qui se bat contre qui ni pourquoi
hier les palestiniens ou les
phalangistes
ce soir ce sont les syriens avec les
habituels bilan 22 morts hier après midi
en italie le cinquième tour de
l'élection présidentielle n'a rien donné
à un sixième tour devait avoir lieu en
fin d'après midi nous n'en connaissons
pas encore les résultats il est
toutefois peu probable que l'italie soit
dotée d'un président de la république
dès ce soir
en france si l'on en croit un sondage de
la sofres sondage publié par la vie
française 82% des dirigeants
d'entreprise garde confiance dans la
politique économique du gouvernement
et pourtant ces chefs d'entreprise
semble bien acquis 73% d'entre eux
pensent que l'inflation va s'accélérer
69% redoutent une concurrence étrangère
accrue et 45% estiment qu'une réduction
des effectifs de leur société doit être
attendue dans les mois qui viennent il
n'en reste pas moins que plus d'un chef
d'entreprise sur deux se déclare
finalement plutôt optimiste
c'est une semaine très importante qui
s'ouvre en france mardi le chef de
l'état reçoit à l'elysée les
représentants de la majorité messieurs
le canoë et chinaud pour l'udf et chirac
et l'abbé pour le rpr et puis mercredi
ce sera au tour de monsieur mitterrand
d'être reçu au palais présidentiel en
compagnie de monsieur gaston defferre et
puis aussi autour de monsieur ballanger
monsieur marché avait bien été invité
mais il ne pourra se rendre à cette
invitation élyséenne est actuellement en
voyage à l'étranger
la discussion aussi bien avec la
majorité qu'avec l'opposition aura pour
thème le prochain sommet des pays
industrialisés qui se tiendra à bonn à
la mi juillet mais on peut tout de même
aujourd'hui se poser une petite question
que vont se dire messieurs giscard
d'estaing et chirac à plusieurs reprises
ces dernières semaines le leader du rpr
a critiqué la politique définie par le
chef de l'état est appliquée par le
gouvernement de monsieur raymond barre
le dernier sujet de divergence c'est
l'espagne jeudi lors de son voyage
officiel de l'autre côté des pyrénées
monsieur giscard d'estaing s'est déclaré
très favorable à l'entrée de l'espagne
dans le marché commun le jour même
monsieur chirac a fait quelques réserves
hier soir à castelnaudary il a été plus
précis pour le leader du rpr élargir la
communauté européenne serait une erreur
capitale
alors notre copain s'agit-il simplement
d'un petit désaccord de plus vient cette
hostilité répéter et à l'entrée de
l'espagne dans le marché commun s'ajoute
à bien d'autres critiques jacques chirac
a fait
et ces derniers temps lieu la critique
de la politique africaine du président
de la république
la critique de la politique économique
de raymond barre assortie d'une critique
peut être plus fondamental de
libéralisme qui inspire cette politique
et puis il ya eu une opposition sur des
points plus particuliers par exemple l
opposition à la réforme du mode de
scrutin des élections municipales
et puis les réticences sur le projet de
cumul des mandats bref dans le oui mais
de jacques chirac que les mets se
multiplient et se précise jacques chirat
cultive la différence
l on est un peu à ramener à ce climat de
tension qu'il y avait à l'intérieur de
la majorité avant les législatives au
milieu de même quelques nuances quelques
nuances d'abord quelques différences de
situation avant les législatives et bien
précisément il y avait la perspective
des législatives qui pouvaient
redistribuer les cartes
aujourd'hui il n'a pas d'échéance
électorale avant 1980 les élections
présidentielles et puis la position du
président de la république est sorti
renforcé des élections législatives même
si jacques chirac est le rpr a contribué
à cette victoire il ya aussi je crois
des nuances dans l'attitude de jacques
chirac première nuance il semble que ce
ne soit plus une fronde personnel comme
autant par exemple de sa candidature à
la mairie de paris mais que c'est une
critique plus politique des orientations
et des décisions prises
et puis pendant la campagne des
législatives jacques chirac avait voulu
semble-t-il surtout se donner une image
musclé qui le déporter vers la droite
aujourd'hui il semble recentrer
davantage son image vers le gaullisme
les critiques qu'ils formulent sont
effectivement des critiques au nom des
principes gaulliste alors pourquoi se
poser la question où je te les ovales et
le choc eh bien oui bien sûr c'est la
grande question qu'on se posait déjà
avant les législatives qu'on se pose
depuis les désaccords de jacques chirac
avec l'opposition sont plus importants
que ces désaccords avec le gouvernement
il n'a donc pas apparemment des
solutions de rechange alors ce qu'il
peut faire c'est exprimé bien haut et
bien fort son désaccord sur un certain
nombre de points pour empêcher que les
décisions soient prises ou pour les
retarder et puis peut-être d'une façon
plus générale poursuivre sur une voie
étroite ne pas partager la
responsabilité de la politique qui est
menée mais ne pas prendre non plus la
responsabilité d'y mettre fin ce n'est
pas facile pour monsieur giscard
d'estaing à ses 15 premiers jours du
mois de juillet seront consacrés donc
presque exclusivement aux grandes
négociations internationales avant le
sommes
et de brême à la mi-juillet les neuf de
la communauté européenne vont se
retrouver à bonn toujours en allemagne
jeudi et vendredi prochains sujets
essentiels de cette négociation
l'économie mais aussi la politique
africaine de l'europe en ce domaine
la position de la france est connue mais
nous connaissons aussi maintenant la
position de l'allemagne
le chancelier ouest allemand monsieur
helmut schmidt rentrer d'un voyage
officiel sur le continent africain
le premier du genre d'ailleurs monsieur
schmitt a visité le nigeria et la zambie
notre envoyé spécial permanent à bonn
michel meyer a suivi pour nous ce voyage
il a pu à cette occasion il interviewait
monsieur helmut chip pour la première
fois le champ chez les ouest allemand
explique donc la politique de son pays
vis-à-vis des pays africains c'est cette
île-etat vu que je vous propose
maintenant le stress peut-on dire qu'il
y a élargi cement du conflit est ouest à
l'afrique
et cela vous aviez besoin afrique en ce
que bent je n'irai pas aussi loin dans
la formulation mais ce danger existe
quand shawn d'acheter et de façon bien
il reste que des pays occidentaux comme
la france la grande bretagne les états
unis et l'allemagne en américain ont été
nettement plus prudent et réservé que
l'urss cuba et en matière de
participation ou d'immixion éventuelle
dans les conflits inter africain et
bendahmane ont testé je suis d'avis que
ces conflits africains doivent être
solutionnés par les africains eux mêmes
et que les états industriels doivent
offrir des aides économiques et non loin
des armes des avions ou des fins dans ce
contexte je suis donc critique envers
l'engagement soviétique en afrique mais
que peut faire les européens pour
stabiliser l'afrique et yat-il accord
franco allemand sur la manière d'aider
d'intervenir
dans une intervention mal ce que les
européens et la communauté ont de plus
important à faire est de promouvoir les
d'économique en afrique cela dans un
esprit de coopération entre partenaires
égaux mathen que c'est là une idée
communément admise en europe
le président giscard d'estaing va plus
loin encore en proposant des aides
économiques et financières encore plus
spécifique
m nous en avons pris connaissance et
sommes à l'étude de ces propositions en
ce qui concerne mon pays je tiens
cependant à préciser que nous nous
associerons jamais à des livraisons
d'armes et que nous n'en verrons jamais
de soldats que ce matériel
cela dit j'ai remarqué qu'ici en afrique
on observera avec un grand intérêt si le
sommet économique de juillet 17 pays
industrialisés évoluera de manière
égoïste car ou si comme nous en avons
l'intention les intérêts et les attentes
des pays en voie de développement seront
aussi pris en considération seraient
indemnisés mon doit-on s'attendre à des
résultats spectaculaires du sommet je
pense à la fin de la récession et à
l'éventuel rôle de locomotive de la part
de l'allemagne fédérale des locomotives
de via shaft soudan et dans l'est
il est préférable de ne pas attendre de
résultats spectaculaires de ce sommet il
s'agit d'une quatrième rencontre sur les
problèmes économiques mondiaux
elle succède à celle de rambouillet
porto rico et londres landes
ces deux rencontres n'ont certainement
pas permis d'éliminer la crise
structurelle que traverse l'économie
mondiale
cela reste vrai pour ce quatrième sommet
les trois précédentes ont cependant
permis de limiter avec le succès les
effets d'une crise
qui aurait pu être grave comme c'est le
cas dans les années 30 de telles
conférences n'existait pas et les hits à
travailler les uns contre les autres ce
n'est plus le cas et dans ce sens ce
sommet peut être tout à fait positive en
ce qui concerne le rôle de l'allemagne
fédérale
c'est effectivement qu'il est à la mode
de nous interpeller pour que nous en
faisions a cependant fait de
propositions précises
je ne trouve donc pas nécessaire que les
mots des plus extravagantes soit suivi
par tout le monde
situer par rapport au monde l'économie
allemande est beaucoup trop petit pour
jouer le rôle d'une locomotive d'un
stade il y aura succès à ce sommet si
toutes les nations industrielles
européennes mais aussi américaines et
japonaises
elle adopte une politique tendant au
même but le plein emploi plus de
croissance
une plus grande stabilité monétaire et
la préservation des conditions
internationales de travail et défense
c'est à dire le refus de tout
protectionnisme commercial rectorat
internationale à bright side of china et
donc finlandaise protection des sources
l'interview politique et économique de
monsieur helmut schmidt qui sera
largement commentée
l'algérie s'apprête à célébrer ce sera
demain le 16e anniversaire de
l'indépendance et oui cela se passait le
3 juillet 1962 l'algérie est un pays
jeune avec une population d'enfants et
d'adolescents extrêmement importante et
beaucoup de ceux qui demain célébreront
cette indépendance pourtant tous
pressentent n'en n'auront aucun souvenir
16 ans le temps de passer de la petite
enfance à l'âge d'homme
mais demain pour célébrer les fêtes il y
aura aussi un absent l'un des principaux
artisans de l'indépendance de l'algérie
ahmed ben bella ne sera pas dans une
tribune officielle depuis 13 ans depuis
l'année 1965 le premier des chefs
historiques de la révolution algérienne
vit en résidence surveillée depuis 13
ans rares sont ceux qui ont pu lui
parler ou le voir la bouffer tout le
monde
je m'excuse encore de l'expression il a
mis tout le monde au tease à six coups
bas et bendahmane oncle je suis d'avis
que ces conflits africains doivent être
solutionnés par les africains eux mêmes
et que les états industriels doivent
offrir des aides économiques et non
point des armes des avions ou des chats
dans ce contexte je suis donc critique
envers l'engagement soviétique en
afrique
mais que peuvent faire les européens
pour stabiliser l'afrique et y à t'il
accord franco allemand sur la manière
d'aider une d'intervenir interventions
européennes et assure que les européens
et la communauté ont de plus important à
faire est de promouvoir l'aide
économique en afrique cela dans un
esprit de coopération entre partenaires
égaux en afrique à human c'est là une
idée communément admise en europe
le président giscard d'estaing va plus
loin encore en proposant des aides
économiques et financières encore plus
spécifique ce qui n'a fait qu'un même
nous en avons pris connaissance et
sommes à l'étude de ces propositions en
ce qui concerne mon pays je tiens
cependant à préciser que nous nous
associerons jamais à des livraisons
d'armes et que nous n'en verrons jamais
de soldats au canada cela dit j'ai
remarqué qu'ici en afrique on observera
avec un grand intérêt si le sommet
économique de juillet des ces pays
industrialisés évoluera de manière
égoïste car ou si comme nous en avons la
tension entre les intérêts et les
attentes des pays en voie de
développement seront aussi pris en
considération
spectacle
très précisément doit-on s'attendre à
des résultats spectaculaires du sommet
je pense à la fin de la récession et à
l'éventuel rôle de locomotive de la part
de l'allemagne fédérale du lokomotiv
d'heure le shaft soudan mais il est
préférable de ne pas attendre de
résultats spectaculaires de ce sommet il
s'agit d'une quatrième rencontre sur les
problèmes économiques mondiaux
elle succède à celle de rambouillet
porto rico et londres landes
ces trois rencontres n'ont certainement
pas permis d'éliminer la crise
structurelle que traverse l'économie
mondiale
cela reste vrai pour ce quatrième sommet
les trois précédents ont cependant
permis de limiter avec le succès les
effets d'une crise qui aurait pu être
grave
comme c'est le cas dans les années de
téléconférences n'existait pas et les
états travailler les uns contre les
autres ce n'est plus le cas et dans ce
sens ce sommet peut être tout à fait
positive en ce qui concerne le rôle de
l'allemagne et des râles c'est
effectivement qu'il est à la morgue de
nous interpeller pour que nous en
faisions plus près cependant fait de
propositions précises
je trouve donc pas nécessaire que les
modes les plus extravagantes soit suivi
par tout le monde
situer par rapport au monde l'économie
allemande est beaucoup trop petit pour
jouer le rôle d'une locomotive
il y aura succès à ce sommet si toutes
les nations industrielles européennes
mais aussi américaines et japonaises
adopte une politique tendant au même but
le plein emploi plus de croissance
une plus grande stabilité monétaire et
la préservation des conditions
internationales de travail et défense
c'est à dire le refus de tout
protectionnisme commercial reste a
raconté international aboie thaïlande à
saitama et donc flambé de protection d
une interview politique et économique de
monsieur helmut schmidt qui sera
largement commentée
l'algérie s'apprête à célébrer ce sera
demain le 16e anniversaire de
l'indépendance et oui cela se passait le
3 juillet 1962 l'algérie est un pays
jeune avec une population d'enfants et
d'adolescents extrêmement importante et
beaucoup de ceux qui demain célébreront
cette indépendance pourtant tous
pressentent n'en n'auront aucun souvenir
16 ans le temps de passer de la petite
enfance à l'âge d'homme
mais demain pour célébrer les fêtes il y
aura aussi un absent l'un des principaux
artisans de l'indépendance de l'algérie
ahmed ben bella ne sera pas dans une
tribune officielle depuis 13 ans depuis
l'année 1965 le premier des chefs
historiques de la révolution algérienne
vite en résidence surveillée depuis 13
ans rares sont ceux qui ont pu lui
parler
le voir la bouffer tout le monde je
m'excuse encore de l'expression il a mis
tout le manteau des institutions et tous
les taxes au frigidaire pour régenter
l'algérie exactement c'était à alger le
19 juin 65 le commandant des blindés ce
l'umam annonçait ainsi le renversement
du premier président de la république
algérienne ahmed benbella ses chars qui
venait de figurer dans le film la
bataille d'alger prenaient position aux
carrefours de la capitale
des manifestants criaient encore vive
ben bella mais il était trop tard
après trois années de pouvoir le premier
chef de l'état algérien se trouvait déjà
en résidence surveillée le colonel
boumédiène s'installe est à sa place
il allait faire disparaître de
l'histoire officielle de l'algérie
le nom même de ahmad ben bella treize
ans après le coup d'état
on s'interroge encore sur le sort de ben
bella est il encore vivant
dia qu'elle ne l'ait pas vu depuis le
début de sa détention
son avocate affirme qu'il vit toujours
fait absolument la preuve que ben bella
à l'heure actuelle est vivant je sais
qu'à plusieurs reprises on a fait courir
des bruits sur sa mort et ça me paraît
un peu inquiétant parce que c'est louis
venez de sources officielles algériennes
et je me suis toujours demandé et nous
nous sommes toujours demandé au comité
et parmi les gens qui s'intéressait au
sort du président ben bella si ce
n'était pas des ballons d'essai pour
voir quelles seraient les réactions de
l'opinion at internationale au cas où il
disparaîtrait dans une série de dessins
naïfs un hebdomadaire avait reconstitué
sa vie en résidence surveillée à 40 km
d'alger gardé par 300 soldats
benbella c'est ainsi marié en 71 avec
une journaliste dans sa prison à l'ombre
des mitraillettes
le couple a même adopté deux enfants
malgré les fouilles
sa famille peut sortir librement mais
pas lui sa popularité gêne encore le
régime
c'est l'opinion de celui qui fut son
seul conseiller français eh bien je
crois que si ben bella ne représente
plus je pense
un grand danger pour le régime du
président boumédiène qui a repris très
largement la politique de son
prédécesseur
c'est que ben bella est intouchable
c'est d'abord un militant
révolutionnaire irréprochable pour le
peuple algérien
c'est ensuite un président de la
république qui a été élu dans des
conditions légales qui a exercé son
pouvoir pendant trois ans dans les
conditions difficiles de l'algérie
indépendante qui n'a pas de sang sur les
mains et qui a toujours essayé de
ménager les uns et les autres pour
permettre
tous les fils d'algérie de construire
leur pays alors je crois que ce passé
révolutionnaire le fait qu'il était
longtemps dans les prisons françaises
qu'il était élu démocratiquement et
qu'il est sorti le pays du chaos au
lendemain de l'indépendance fait qu'il
existe un mythe ben bella même si les
plus jeunes aujourd'hui ne le
connaissent pas ahmed ben bella a passé
plus du tiers de sa vie en détention
pourtant il n'a jamais été jugé
aujourd'hui une certaine opposition se
reconnaît encore en son nom bien que le
président du néo viennent affirme qu'il
n'a plus sa place dans la vie politique
algérienne mais son maintien en
résidence surveillée et sans doute le
résultat de la confrontation de deux
tendances au sein du régime
les partisans de sa liquidation et ceux
de sa libération
18 ans de réclusion pour le docteur
birague 12 ans de réclusion pour
christian portek huit ans de la même
peine pour josé picard la cour d'assises
de la haute garonne qui siège est à
toulouse a rendu cette nuit tard dans la
nuit son verdict dans la sphère de
l'assassinât de retrouver leurs marques
et si vous avez suivi pour antenne de ce
procès oui les jurés de la haute-garonne
6 1 et 3 femmes sont des gens
intelligents on se demandait un peu ce
qu'il avait pu retenir d'un dossier
aussi complexe qui leur était révélé de
façon aussi décousu lors de chaque
témoignage il fallait aborder un élément
nouveau
sans avoir jamais une vue globale pour
tout synthèse l'acte d'accusation et
pour guide
les rares interventions du président
durant il aura fallu faire la part des
invraisemblances des mensonges aussi des
contradictions et du flou de certains
témoignages dont pourtant on attendait
beaucoup et garder encore après cela la
tête claire pour l'épuisante journée
d'hier 13 heures consacrée au
réquisitoire et aux plaidoiries
règlement de comptes organisé par
birague selon l'avocat général meurtre
téléguidé selon les avocats de christian
portel exécutèrent correction simple
correction qui a mal tourné pour ceux de
joseph picard et puis accusations
invraisemblables ou peut-être complots
malveillants monté après coup birague
est innocent selon les défenseurs
à 2 heures la nuit dernière virag est
déclaré coupable sa peine à deux ans
près répond à la demande de l'avocat
général pour les deux autres on a su
modulé avec soin portait le meurtrier 12
ans picard le comparse huit ans pour le
meurtre de renée trouvé deux ans et demi
après à toulouse
la justice est passée une histoire bien
curieuse est arrivé à quelques 900
américains candidats à une croisière au
bout d'une journée une seule journée de
mer un bon tiers des passagers s'est
mutinée et a dérouté le bateau vers le
port de new york si l'on en croit les
responsables de cette mutinerie
il y avait de quoi d'ailleurs être
mécontents même si cette croisière ne
coûtait pas très cher 150 $ pour trois
jours environ
les cabines étaient non seulement
minuscule paraît-il mais en plus elle
grouillait de cafards et de rats les
douches étaient inexistantes quant aux
services n'en parlons pas je préfère
rester correct le soir à la télévision
normalement les actes de mutineries vous
le savez sont très sévèrement punis dans
la marine il semble bien pourtant que
les autorités maritimes américaine n'est
pas l'intention de pendre les révoltés
au grand mât il serait même question de
leur rembourser leur croisière il ne
fait pas très beau donc en ce début de
vacances il faut se trouver de
l'occupation pour les longues journées
de pluie et si vous n'avez rien à faire
je vous propose comme nous l'avons
d'ailleurs fait il y a quelques mois
c'était cet hiver je vous propose
d'aller visiter le petit village de
ferrières
derrière c'est dans le tarn dont loin de
castres un petit village qui est
surprenant ce sont les jeunes qui ont
décidé de s'occuper de l'animation de la
commune alors avec l'aide d'un animateur
du parc régional du languedoc et ils ont
déjà créé un musée une imprimerie et un
atelier de luthier et ce n'est pas fini
alors une preuve s'il en fallait qu avec
quelques subventions des bénévoles et
beaucoup de volonté on peut arriver à
faire revivre une commune aujourd'hui
ferrière vous attend
oui bien aujourd'hui on marie deux
jeunes de ce groupe qui habite villages
dans la montagne du haut languedoc et
c'est le premier mariage dangereux de
jeunes en fait on est un tout petit
village il ya 143 habitants à ferrières
et ce tout petit village est frappée par
l'exode rural comme toute cette région
de montagne du haut languedoc et le
groupe de 23 jeunes décidés il y a déjà
dix ans de faire de l'animation de
prendre en compte un petit peu tout ce
qui intéresse la vie la qualité de la
vie et c'est pour ça que vous les voyez
avec des capes
les caps qui représente d'un petit peu
leur fierté d'exister avec toute leur
volonté leur volonté d'agir pour sauver
leur village
mais on s'est connus ici à l'occasion
d'une fête locale quoi dit et l'a fait
justement de la commune libre
les dix ans d'anniversaire et c'est là
qu'on s'est connus
brel du moulin c'est un des plus
importants chantiers que l'on mène
actuellement c'est même le plus
important on est en train de refaire la
toiture de ce bâtiment et on installe à
l'imprimerie
on n'a pas de même des ardoises et des
voisins pour le faire dans les normes
anciennes
à
je suis fonctionnaire à toulouse je vais
faire de la petite composition pendant
au moins trois heures pour moi
fonctionnaires travaillant textile ils
ont agi travail de plus de 8 ans du
temps libre je viens aider comme
l'imprimeur man et son imprimerie nous
passer de la récupérer pour créer des
emplois sur ferrières les jeunes restés
au village
quand nous passions faire ici des cartes
de visite des affiches ni tracts puis
peut être des livres par la suite on
fait ça n'est pas moi quoi alors oui
adacore bon j'arrive un merci à ben ce
téléphone à l'imprimerie est encore
toute une histoire
parce que pour l'amener ici les
l'administration des ptt devait planter
80 poteau alors on a voulu éviter qu'on
abîme le site et les jeunes de ferrières
ont fait qu'à un kilomètre 500 de
trancher pour passer le câble en
souterrain jusqu'ici au rwanda il marche
on est fiers
oui parce que ça c'est la maison des
jeunes en fait c'est la ferme de
l'asgard ils ont là c'était il ya cinq
ans et il a fallu à payer 5 millions et
en cinq ans on est arrivé à rembourser
les prêts que certains amis nous avez
fait pour qu'on puisse l'acheter là
dedans on a installé notre foyer c'est
là qu'on se rencontre et en même temps
une collection d'arts et traditions
populaires du folklore qui fait partie
qui devient le troisième musée de
ferrières mais pour ce faire il a fallu
installer des poutres et servait normes
travaux mais si on y passe là aussi
quelques dimanches dans cette vieille
ferme on essaie de reconstituer
l'intérieur ancien des vieilles fermes
de la région avec tous les objets
anciens qu'il ya comme par exemple cette
vieille bayas nous a été prêtée dans
dans la région qui s'est rassis
nullement faire lever le pen quand il
est tout frais que le maire l'intérieur
en fait la commune libre a déjà bien et
réalisations ici c'est le musée du
protestantisme il ya aussi la maison de
l'artisanat et c'est sa première
réalisation
elle date d'il y a 10 11 ans même et on
ya consacré beaucoup de loisirs de 200
documents on est passé à 12 milles
le musée de ferrières et le deuxième en
france c'est dire qu'avec du bénévolat
un peu de temps et surtout de la bonne
volonté on fait quand même de bonnes
choses
ferrières dans le tarn la loi de castres
tout au long de cette semaine nous
allons vous faire visiter d'ailleurs les
parcs régionaux et les parcs nationaux
français les plus importants en tout cas
c'est un rendez vous que vous fixent
tous les soirs dans c'est la vie alain
valentini et puisque j'en suis au rendez
vous je vous rappelle aussi qu antenne 2
demain consacre toute sa journée à la
grande bretagne
notre journal de 20h sera donc présentée
en direct de londres par patrick poivre
d'arvor sport je ne reviens pas sur
l'ensemble des résultats de cette
journée vous les connaissez maintenant
grâce à stade 2 je vous rappelle
simplement que le grand prix de france
d'automobiles qui se courait au
castellet a été remportée par
l'américain mario andretti sur lotus les
coureurs du tour de france
e.on une journée difficile ils sont
passés de 143 km 500 sur une bicyclette
et sous la pluie en bus
l'étape saint-amand-les-eaux saint
germain en laye a apporté quelques
changements au classement général les
avait pris le large et l'étape a été
remportée par un allemand tu as l'air
devant jacques bossis un équipier de
bernard hinault troisième bernard friot
au classement général la veille and race
a perdu ce soir son maillot jaune et ses
beaux si ce qu'il a endossé demain 4e
étape
evreux caen par la route des écoliers
bien sûr et puis il y avait aussi un
tiercé aujourd'hui se tient ces secours
est à saint cloud il s'agissait du
handicap de saint cloud avec 2800 mètres
à parcourir pour les 22 partants
finalement mariage à bhl l'a emporté
devant aedgency et compte grande
combinaison gagnante le 6 le 8 et le 2
les rapports pour 5 francs s'inscrit sur
notre petit écran 6535 front dans
l'ordre pour 500 bien sûr et 1307 francs
dans un ordre différent
voilà il est 20 heures et 27 minutes
pratiquement ce cette édition est
terminée à 22h27 22h30
hervé claude sera avec vous pour notre
dernier journal je vous souhaite donc de
passer une très bonne soirée sur antenne
2 françois